♪ Four and three
and two and wa, one
(energetic rap music)
♪ Wa one
- What's up guys?
I'm Matt FX, Music
Supervisor of Broad City
and here's our recap for
episodes two and three,
Pussy Weed and Working Girls.
First up, we've got a track
called 1977 by Ana Tijoux.
1977 is a very cool
Latin rap track,
running under the cold
open of Working Girls.
It's a really great kinda
identity piece in the show,
kind of showing how
the two different girls
go about their days.
Obviously Ilana's
a bit of a slacker,
Abbi's a bit of an overachiever.
Gotten a lot of really great
feedback on this track,
so we're really happy to
feature it in this episode.
("1977" by Ana Tijoux)
Secondly, we're gonna
feature a bit about
an artist named Hot Sugar.
Hot Sugar is a producer
who's worked with everyone
from The Roots to Das Racist.
He makes incredibly interesting,
unique hip hop beats
that have an almost Willy
Wonka sort of magic to them.
He's actually someone
who has given us
a bunch of music for the show,
all of which is unreleased,
so I can't even give
you track titles.
I can tell you that his music
is in a bunch of transitions
in episode three
as well as some of
the later episodes
in the season.
Next up, we've got another
featured transition
in episode three
in the instrumental dub
of Badman by Doctor Jeep.
We feature Badman
in a transition,
right before Ilana's in
the train with the cops.
The cops are just walking by
while she's a
little uncomfortable
hiding contraband
within her purse.
Perfect idea to use this
track as it starts off
with a little siren woop and
having the cops walking by
just fits real nicely together.
(siren and heavy base beat)
(train moving down the track)
Last song featured in this recap
is another episode three jam,
See You Leave by
the inimitable RJD2.
See You Leave is running in
the dentist waiting room scene
as Abbi's waiting for Ilana
to get out of a procedure.
It's a really early
scene in our season
where we get to show
Abbi's fun-loving side
and I think RJD2's kind of
fun, slow, humble groove
was just a perfect fit
for her personality.
("See You Leave" by RJD2)
And that was our catch-up recap
for episodes two and three,
Pussy Weed and Working Girls.
Thanks so much for watching.
Follow me on Twitter
@MattFXFXFXFX, four times,
if you have any questions
about the music on the show.
Follow Broad City on
Facebook, Tumblr, or Twitter,
and we'll see you next week.